[Musik]
qualität wird ganz groß geschrieben und
an der stelle darf ich euch mal wieder
ganz recht herzlich willkommen heißen zu
einer weiteren episode
ich habe seit einem halben jahr nicht
mehr auf trick dogs reagiert von daher
bin ich wirklich gespannt und freue mich
auf eure videos 2 1 los
es macht spaß sagte kaeser
reichen gibt eine wahrheit
[Musik]
ich glaube dass man jetzt bereits gründe
genug warum ich seit märz um halben jahr
nichts mehr am hut hatte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wer das komplett gottlos erst 13 tage
nach der therapie ich freue mich auf
jeden fall viel besser danke nochmal an
francesca lachten nur auf seinen starken
fuss aber hat einer von euch das geld da
überhaupt auf dem boden gesehen
ich ziehe ahlmann luca hier wieder max
zu sein habe ich liebe salami muss mal
wieder wen soll ich kenne dich nicht
wobei vielleicht bist du meine nachbarin
schöne grüße einmal nachbarn die jetzt
gerade zuschauer der schweiz einfach wer
schwitzt einfach ich stütze einfach um
gott ich kann ja schwitzen was ist mit
mir was ist mit dir stuttgart schien das
will da bist gott ich liebe ich weiß
nein
stuttgart lieber ich du warst immer
offener natürlich war ich auf einem
gemälde oder kann aber was ist mit dir
herausgebrochen wer du bist single oh
gott ich muss dir hält natürlich muss
ich dir helfen wenn ich sowas sehe
wünsche ich mir immer dass diese frühere
ansicht von wegen das internet wenn nur
für katzen videos da einfach recht
behalten hätte
wenn die party zu ende ist man komplett
besoffen ist und gerade zu seinen
nachdenklichen augenblick bekommt
[Musik]
erreicht jetzt auch mit der katze mannes
video hier rein
[Musik]
wenn du innerlich tot bist aber den
therapeuten sage soll zeit mit freunden
verbringen
[Musik]
jedes mädchen wird schwach wenn man also
das ist krank er ist heftig mädels
werden schwach wenn man denen die
sauerstoffzufuhr abschneidet ist es
brutal das wusste ich nicht
[Musik]
ich hab mir auf jeden fall gedacht
mensch luca da bist du schon mal auf tik
tok unterwegs sein kann es ja auch bei
deiner besten freundin von hinten
vorbeischauen
sandra also wenn ihr noch nicht folgen
sollte tut das gern ihr seht ihren namen
hier jetzt ein bis zu jungen wirklich
es tut mir leid ok thomas mach's gut
[Musik]
der unterschied zum geringverdiener ich
habe einen tollen und ihr nicht dinge
die ein geringverdienern ist kennt warum
kennt ein geringverdiener kein punkten
was ist das hier
ich verdiene ich genug spielen immer
mobile.de
[Musik]
ich gesagt dass ich mich gerade
schneller verliebt sich prince irren
kann bislang haben wir ein sehr
entspanntes spiel hier in der
estländischen zweiten liga keine
auffälligen situation aber zweimal an
und schießt dann noch mal hinterher der
schiri zeigt sofort die rote karte
runter mit der bitte bundesliga nicht
kommentieren michael jungs und ich hab
mir jetzt 30 zentimeter in rachen danach
erst dieses papier das man spielt und
zwar ist deine frage du stellst eine
frage und müssen sie ehrlich beantworten
sie macht mich als ringen das ist so
heute der inspiration des fotografen
bahn geleistet und assistenz ja ich gebe
meinen schweren auch mal mit dem
bulldozer drüber es ist ein stift mit
einem bulldozer drüber fahrer wird das
ganze so aussehen schwingen wir es vom
ersten ganz begeistert dort gerne etwas
mit dem bekenner auf jeden fall gut
geklappt
das ding hat anderthalb millionen
aufrufe wenn man weiss einmal schwarz
würdet ihr die trage mia schwarz oder
weiß wie wichtig eine gute idee für den
an der stelle wo ich das heute wieder
jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
dass ich mal wieder auf doch reagiert
habe dann hat gerne einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da abonniert main
kanal und klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr
neue videos nicht
auf 17 uhr 30